we are about to finish up if you're if
you're following along at home you know
how I said in the syllabus that there's
these different subsections within each
topic so V 1.1 was like the introduction
to three-dimensional vectors which
really didn't have very much in it it's
like hey here's a z-axis what kinds of
things can you do with it
um this week we have been looking
through a v 1.2 these further operations
um and you can see the things that we've
covered so far we're kind of going to uh
finish up with v 1.2 today which will
pave the way for vectors and Vector
equations of lines next week now the
thing that we're going to do today is a
little bit like remember I told you
about ratio division ratio division
doesn't explicitly come up anywhere here
but it's a really great way to learn
some of the skills that the syllabus
wants of us right so I'm going to be
doing much the same thing today with
this idea of projection it's not
explicitly mentioned but it's just such
a it's such a an applicable idea it's
very clever it builds on what we've done
in extension one I know you've um you've
met projection before but what I'm going
to do is I'm kind of going to expect
maybe this is an unfair expectation but
I'm kind of going to expect that you you
know maybe the formula for projection
don't worry I'm not going to ask you to
recite it um there are multiple ones if
you remember that but perhaps don't have
much of the understanding about where
this goes right or where it comes from
so that's what we're going to focus on
today and then see how it applies does
that make sense you've got a rough idea
where we're going to head today so what
I'd love you to do is start by drawing
for me a pair of vectors you can make
them much like the vectors that I've
drawn here but part of the point of
everything that we're doing in vectors
is you can do it with any arbitrary
vector or vectors it's just that I've
just placed them in two spots that are
reasonably convenient to me
for me the uh first explanation of
projection because you're like throwing
all these formulas and um and notation
and symbols around and you've got to
know like what's the meaning of the
thing you're doing okay
the way this was explained to me the
very first time is this sentence I've
written here right when you are
projecting the first thing you do is you
work out what we call the scalar
projection I should actually just start
that jot that down for you the scalar
projection
and like all scalers
um it's a it's a one-dimensional
quantity and that one-dimensional
quantity is the length of the shadow
that one vector casts upon another as it
were so what I want you to imagine is
maybe I'll move this down just a teeny
bit
if you can imagine you know the sun
hanging out here and it's it's shining
down upon these two vectors and you can
sort of
um in fact let's draw this on right you
can imagine this top Vector a casting a
shadow shadow onto this bottom Vector B
like so right now what we're trying to
work out is hey this Shadow down oh that
was a bit thicker than I intended so
this Shadow down here there we go
it has a length
um that length is what we call the
scalar projection we're going to work
that out first and then we are going to
um also if we want to include the disc
the diff sorry the distance that's why I
just worked out we're going to include
the direction of this Vector in what we
call the vector projection because
scalar's just a length the vector
projection is um when you send it in a
particular direction right
so how does one go about doing this
again I wonder if there's any
um any sort of uh ideas kicking around
from when you encountered this in
extension one what I'm going to do is
I'm going to do this from scratch and it
will feel a little bit theoretical I'm
very deliberately not really going to
give you a worked example on this or
maybe just a very brief one because it's
just the idea that I want us to focus on
and the geometry and the relationships
between this okay
now don't forget we're in three
dimensions but even though we're in
three dimensions you can always find a
plane that uh two vectors will sit in do
you remember Mrs Oz I don't think you're
in the room but I asked Ryan and Sean to
arbitrarily yeah you saw the recording
yep um so if trying to recreate it it's
hard you need you need more hands
basically which is why the two of you
guys were perfect so for any two
arbitrary vectors facing in any
direction we can find a plane that they
both sit upon and that as it were is our
piece of paper that we're looking at at
the moment okay so even though I'm in
three dimensions I can still reason in
two Dimensions now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to use the dot product to
help me work out what the length of this
Shadow is and here's how we're going to
go about it right the dot product helps
us work out as you can see here like
there's an angle between A and B if a
was parallel to B don't draw this but
just suppose a was parallel to B like so
then that the length of that shadow it's
kind of like you don't need to do any
working because the length of the Shadow
is just the length of a right
um but of course normally we're
considering When A and B are parallel so
we need to work out this relationship
between the angles of those vectors
right so what I'm going to do and I'm
going to ask you to follow here with me
is put a few constructions on here to
help us now uh what we'll do is we'll
say first we're going to try and work
out this uh this Vector C I'm going to
call that the shadow right what I'm
really going to start out working out is
what is the length of this Vector right
that's the length of the Shadow right
now I can see that same length is
actually it appears in another place if
I go up here it sort of Slide the shadow
up towards the top Vector right this
this Vector up here has the same uh
length right because it's just opposite
sides of a rectangle
the reason why this is helpful is
because I can now match this up with the
angle between uh this sort of
repositioned Vector C is going to be the
same as the angle between if you can
imagine picking up a and putting it tail
to tail with B you'd get the same Theta
right like it's going to be I guess I
can you don't have to draw this but if I
duplicated this over here
Tada you can actually see uh it's that
same Theta right it's just in a
different spot okay so let me get rid of
that because that's unnecessarily uh
clouding our diagram there we go so how
do we work this thing out well I've got
uh the length I can work out the length
of this Vector using just the the
magnitude of any vector and you can see
here what I've got actually is a right
angled triangle in here so I can use
some pretty simple trigonometry and
relate this to the dot product right so
let's actually uh jot some of this down
I'm just going to use my space on the
right hand side because I've not left
myself in no space so I'm just going to
say by trigonometric ratios
what is the
particular ratio that connects the two
sides that I've got here and I fixed my
laser pointer so it should work I've got
a and I've got C what's the ratio
first time yeah fantastic the cosine is
adjacent over hypotenuse so I'm just
going to say cause of theta is equal to
C that magnitude on a like so
now uh this is really helpful because
what I can basically say is hey that
that cosine of theta that appears in the
dot product right so I can say let's use
the formula for the dot product that has
cosine in it so the angle between the
two and that'll give me an equation that
doesn't have thetas in it and that's
really nice because we tend to get our
vectors in component form right so if
I've got all the components then I don't
need to work out Theta separately so
here's what I'm going to write I'm going
to say uh a dot b
what's that going to be equal to well I
I would normally say magnitude of a
magnitude of B and then cos Theta but I
don't need to say cos Theta because I've
got an expression for that
magnitude magnitude of a I've got an
expression for cos Theta up the top here
oops
let's highlight properly shall we can't
reach it there we go I've got this
um expression up here which is the same
as cos Theta it's equivalent but it just
doesn't have any of um the angle in it
so let me just grab that
again sorry I'm just going to be a
little bit cheap and do that like so and
hopefully you can see like oh I can I
can do some canceling here right so what
I'm going to do is I'm on the
denominator there you can see that
magnitude of a it's going to cancel
with the magnitude of a that comes from
the dot product formula
so now what I've got here is just and
I'll write this on the left hand side
because if you remember the thing I'm
trying to work out the length of the
Shadow it's this magnitude of C so I'm
going to get towards making that the
subject so I'm going to write that on
the left hand side
that's just equal to a dot b because all
the rest of the things have canceled
okay
all right now let's keep going I'm now
going to say if what I want is just the
magnitude of that Vector the length of
the Shadow I just have to divide through
both sides by the magnitude of B which I
have over here right so let's go ahead
and write that so I've got a dot b on
the numerator and then I'm dividing
by the magnitude of Bin okay now this is
this is fine this is all true but I can
write this in a slightly simpler form if
you can help me remember that actually
if you take some arbitrary vector and
you divide that vector by its magnitude
what what do you get when you do that
process if you divide a magnet sorry a
vector by its own length yeah very good
this gives you the unit vector or I
should say the corresponding unit Vector
for that because if it was a vector
offer this particular angle and it was
15 units long and then you divide by 15.
well now you've got the direction is
still there you haven't changed the
direction at all but you've divided by
15 so now it's one unit so that's what
makes it the unit Vector okay
so what I can do is I can say all right
this um this scalar
uh projection the length of the Shadow
the magnitude you just see they're all
the same thing what that's equal to is a
DOT and if you remember we write the
unit Vector as the same as B but with a
hat over the top okay so there's there's
the unit Vector there
so this thing here is uh what we were
describing before where did I write it
yes I read it in purple this thing is
what we call the scalar projection
remember
when you do this dot product all you get
is a number at the end right and this
particular number this scalar number is
the length of that shadow okay
so what I can do is I can just sort of
extend that just a little bit and if I
said just going back to our original
diagram if I wanted to know not just the
length of the Shadow but like where is
that shadow facing then all I have to do
is multiply by the the direction part
right now if you have a look here
the direction is given by B but I don't
want to have like the length of it
because that would change the length of
the shadow that I've just calculated so
what do I multiply by to get the
direction of B without any kind of
change in its magnitude
it's the unit Vector again right now
this this is important because um what
we're working out here now is the vector
projection so now I've got some
direction involved I remember when I
first encountered this formula and uh
what we've got here is no longer a
magnitude it is the actual Vector c
um it's a dot b hat but then that whole
thing which is a scalar we just multiply
that by B hat again and remember look at
this and I was like why are there so
many B hats in here
um it's going to get worse
um but why why is it there twice and the
answer is it's there once because of
this operation up here when we said oh I
can just write this as the the unit
Vector so that simplifies and then it's
here a second time because we are um
restoring the direction of that because
all we have is a scalar right now this
thing here is the idea right this is
what you will see as the notation
um projection of a onto B it's very
weird to say it like that so I'm
actually going to write it explicitly so
it's in the recording you can come back
to it we um we would write this as the
projection
of a onto B now even though that's a bit
of an awkward thing when you read that
um it's a bit like you know with logs
right if I say this
you can say
um log base 2 of 5. so the of five is
the same thing right like this is the
this is the subject and then this is
kind of like the well the base of the
operation it's the same deal here with
the projection right you can literally
see if you go back to the original
diagram B is the is the vector on the
bottom it's the base right and then a is
the thing that's casting the shadow onto
B and that's one of the handy ways to
remember it okay